Welcome to another VC lives open
quarter view.
Ah.
Today, we're going to be doing
the.
82093 R 14 Provision 14
formatted output. This basically
allows you to write something
like.
Example.
And just say stood print. Hello
blah.
This gets us up to the nice
standard of printing that other
room have very pretty. I like it
a lot.
Honestly, it's one of my
favorite new kind of.
Beginner ish features like.
New it's one of my favorite new
features for everyday
developers.
So if you look through it.
Girl.
Let's see.
It's like the wording. There
isn't a significant number of
new API for such a I consider to
be significant feature. We have
our classic print.
Which?
Just prints 2. So now we have
print which prints 2 of file
star where you can choose
whether it's stood out stood
there.
For like a a file that you've
opened.
Similarly print Ln which will
add new line afterwards.
And then we got the V prints.
Forgot print to an ostream. I
actually don't.
Really understand what the
difference between reprint
Unicode.
And be printing on Unicode is
it's.
On to me, I I don't fully
understand that I.
Until can you?
Say something about what this
actually means.
I do not remember it in detail.
I reviewed it and I did a like a
wonder one. You know,
correspondence between Yep, this
seems to do with the standard
says, but I don't recall it in
enough detail to be able to
explain it from scratch.
I think it it's does like UTF 8
conversion or something. I think
that's a difference.
I'd say since my mother
somewhere.
The text is a little tiny. Can
you zoom in a bit?
Wrong with me?
Can you read it now?
Yeah, that should be more
visible for the recording.
So right. So the difference
between viewpoint and Conan
viewpoint nonunit code is that
the print Unicode.
If this is not important on Mac
OS or Linux because they're
streams are never.
Anything other than bites.
On Windows, if you're writing to
a a like a file or to a pipe
like, you're piping output from
one program to another, that'll
be done in by.
However.
If you're writing to the
console, if you want.
Be.
God that that the output to come
up.
When you're using Unicode
characters, you have to actually
convert to UTF 16 and then
prints the console.
And so be print Unicode. Does
this like magic stuff and it
checks if the streamer you're
printing to isn't. Is it console
terminal?
And then it does that Unicode
version. The conversion to you
have 16 and then prints it out
to the.
So this all makes sense.
Like there's also P2539R3.
And this is just saying.
If.
We use the Unicode API. We have
to flush the stream buffer.
And it just means an extra flush
in be printing.
So.
Look at the code.
I'm going to assume that pretty
much all of the.
External API stuff is good
because I skills looked at it
already and my.
Feel like he's really good at
this kind of thing, but what I
really wanna look at.
I did.
I did forget an only realized at
the last minute that we should
Right.
check our API usage for both
operating system dependencies
and app versus desktop. So the
big questions, cuz we have to
target all the way down to win
seven and we need to work on
both desktop and the Windows
Store. We can't use APIs
unconditionally that are only
available on Windows 10 or
Windows 11. And if we use APIs
that are desktop only then that
requires special incantations to
be.
Compatible for store and we
don't have great test coverage
of either. We always test our
stuff on the latest OS and
desktop.
So that's a easy place to mess
up when we're merging changes.
Gonna works on a developer
machine and then it fails. In
this scenario that we don't
really test, but we did look
into it afterwards and we
believe it should be OK. It
looks like all the APIs are
supported down to win seven, and
although Microsoft Docs or
Microsoft learn.
Has some ominous incantations
saying, oh, this is desktop
only. It doesn't appear that the
APIs are in fact supported for
store, so I believe it's OK and
worst case, we're gonna hear
that there's an issue and
involved. Have some if defs or
something, but the features a
leaf it's not modifying existing
code and it's not modifying the
DLL, it's only adding stuff to
the import Lib for binary
compatibility. So I believe the
risk should be low.
But definitely something to
think about.
Yeah, definitely.
So I'm not interested in the
same course for this video
review. What I'm interested in
is.
Look at all the changes first
so.
More test stuff.
You got some stuff moving
around. I believe that this is
just getting moved from.
Girls.
Can you also zoom this in as
much as you can tolerate?
Yeah.
I need to start getting and.
In this inline as well to me.
So yeah, this is all getting
moved.
So.
That's actually look at the
stuff that I wanna talk about,
which is actual windows stuff.
Go to have stream no stream.
This is where the ostream in
our.
And is this includes, we print
no for right?
I don't know. I'm gonna code
different Unicode.
Can't .1. Yeah, OK.
So these are the two things I
really wanted to talk about
today.
We've got.
Thanks.
Went to a a stream as well as
to.
Stood out.
Yeah. So.
Friends.
Tested out is very simply. Print
twisted out print to the stream
stream.
Thanks one.
Now and then print one and the
only difference is that.
Print we pass false to print
simple.
Mental and passed through
different info.
Not sure about that, I I.
Not sure about that
implementation, given that it
will basically double our.
Conscience for these, and I
doubt that it's that important,
but still seems weird to have
this add new line thing.
And if we go here?
Different temple.
Take a file stream.
String.
If they have format ARGS.
And if we're in, if we pass
slash UTF 8 to Seattle so.
We go.
So normally if you write stuff.
And.
Hey.
Collateral. It will be whatever.
Code page you're currently
assigned to. So for example for
me.
The code page is 437 which leave
is US asking like extended US
asking or whatever.
And so so yeah, when it's
looking at this file, we'll say.
Ohh yeah, frosty it's encoded
in.
After you are asking.
Some extensions.
And it'll get put into the
binary as.
If I put something like you
know.
Ohgi.
Now when the compiler is reading
this, this set of bytes in the
actual physical file on desk.
Doesn't really make sense, and
so if we for example print out.
You get random gibberish and
this is what the bites of this
UTF 8 character.
End up getting turned into in
extended US ask.
If you would.
If you want.
To be able to print Unicode to
the console.
You can also.
UTF 8 to see how.
Not like you to fit.
And you need a dash.
You get the same behavior,
however, in the actual compiler
itself. What's happening is it's
seeing this as a UTF 8.
I'm.
Nicole, did you? Did you
recompile with Slash UTF Dash 8I
And.
your terminal's too small? I
couldn't see what happened. Oh,
you did. OK.
OK.
You see the output is actually
the same, because what happens
with black UTF 8?
This is kind of what I wanted to
get to was the compiler.
Generally what was happening is
it was looking at this file it
was saying. Ohh yeah this is.
You ask extended.
Thanks.
We're going to take these fights
in US Skies ended, turn them
into uniform.
And then when we're writing out
the binary, we're going to take
those Unicode characters and
write them to disk in US. Asking
extended because by default it
just uses this, you know.
Edge.
437.
When I and then when the when
the thing runs, what happens is.
It.
It's a very it's like these
three different things that are
going on when the thing runs. It
then takes this stuff in US apps
get extended and writes it to
the console in US ask.
Have you ask ask you extended?
And so.
In order to actually write
Unicode characters in the
console, what you have to do is
change all three parts.
Your.
So first you have to make sure
that the compiler is reading in
UTF 8.
Then you have to make sure that
when it writes it back out, it's
writing it back out and you TFA
into the actual, like,
executable binary.
Why you really when you write it
to the screen?
You have to make sure that it's
being written to the screen.
Unicode characters.
This does would print dots is it
takes care of that final piece.
It says.
We've got this V print unit code
info C.
We print print no format here.
This is what happens.
Is we?
Where's the dirt steer?
Actually happens in.
That is the declaration one.
Different Tina code console.
It's a UTF 8 string.
Converts it.
The UTF 16.
Then.
Note that UTF 8, UTF 16 string
to the console and Windows
treats UTF 16.
Always Unicode. You can always
write whatever you want.
Entertaining, you know, code
thing. And so if you're using
print, you have UTF 8.
And you have UTF 8.
And the binary.
Then we can take that and at
runtime.
Make sure that the UTF 8 comes
out as the correct Unicode
characters on the console.
This is all very confusing and
has a lot of backwards
compatibility kind of hide up
into it.
So if we look here for example.
We go, OK.
If Constexpr stood is ordinary
little literal encoding UTF and
we say OK.
This is how we check.
Go here.
That.
The.
Ah.
The string literals are UTF 8.
If they are UTF, if they are not
UTF 8, actually if they're not
UTF 8, then we just do whatever
the system does because there
isn't really a better way to do
it. We just write the bytes to
the console and then whatever
code page you have is what you
get. There is unfortunately not
a better way to do this.
And ability is.
No, that that's how that all
works.
Separate do you have any
comments or anything you wanna
ask or anything does? Is there
anything that's unclear?
Yeah, it might be useful to
bring up the the old way of
doing it, which is calling the
nonstandard Microsoft specific
functions that were actually
implemented in VS. I think
around the VS 2003 or 2005 time
frame this is done by my
predecessors and I did some
archaeology when I joined the
team and realized wait, like the
CRT has a code path that
actually calls right console W
much the same way that stood
print is doing. If you look for
the.
Magic identifier oh you 16 text
that will bring up the Microsoft
docs.
It's spelled under score O under
score U-16 tax. Yeah, like that.
But not stack overflow. Get
Microsoft learn.
And it's the docs for.
Ah.
Not this, it's UM.
Set Mode Set mode is usually the
doc this.
Yeah, that one.
Yeah. If you look at the second
example here, we got this put
into the docs once I.
I worked with Michael Kaplan to
find out how this works. Yeah,
this example. So these
incantations you need to include
three headers. You call this
magic thing, set mode file node
stood out. Oh you 16 text and
then calling wprintf. Note that
it's wprintf with UTF 16 will
work.
If you don't have that magic
set, mode incantation doesn't
I.
matter if you come to W printf
with totally valid UTF 16, it
will get mangled on its way to
the console. Doesn't matter if
you set the console code page to
UTF 16.
I won't work, but with the magic
incantation it does. Yeah. Try
commenting out the set mode and
see what happens. You won't get
Koshka and then the.
Ideographic characters.
Afterwards, it'll just be
gibberish.
It doesn't even print anything
awesome.
That's great.
Yeah, it used to point to where
I don't know what's going on
here. Yeah, with without the
seven mode doesn't work. That's
because I believe, although it's
been years, so I might not
remember exactly how it works.
Without that, even W printf
tries to do some sort of
conversion on the way to the
console.
And trying to set the console
code page to UTF 8 or 16 it does
not help.
Umm, only grade council. We can
do it properly so that magic
identifier or the magic constant
used to be necessary and now
printf provides a much more
modern and portable way to
achieve the same result. But
ultimately on Windows we gotta
call right Console W so that's
what the implementation is
doing. It's just horribly
complicated. I don't pretend to
understand it in full depth and
I'm very glad that Tyler Brawl
are contributor here. Did the
investigation necessary
implement all that stuff?
So this is all.
Reading your why wouldn't we
confuse things? And it's all
backwards compatibility.
So however, in the future.
If you pass whack I you TF8 to
your compilable.
And you use stood print, you
don't have to worry about any of
this because we've got this new
awesome way of doing things that
does all of the magic stuff for
you.
Let's actually take a look at
this code, which basically we've
got.
Prince, Prince Alan be print
Unicode, be print onion.
No.
Prince to print temple.
You're not like that bull. Add
new line, see.
So we have view print unit code
and pull you print onion code
and pull.
And that OK, so basically what
we're saying is.
This print info.
Does the check for his ordinary
literal encoding YouTube?
And then dispatches to either
reprint Unicode or V print
nonunit.
Which is exactly what he
printing print.
In the Carter, different one.
So.
In.
Ohh.
You.
Different Unicode info be
interesting one getting output
string.
If we had a new line we V
format, the from the string.
You know line otherwise we don't
add a new line.
Really don't understand why this
is too functions.
Why this is completed?
Then we just call stood print no
format and you know.
Because none of code and pull
does the same thing except it
prints no format, no non
Unicode.
We just.
Right to the.
The stir to the stream, so
that's kind of the trivial case.
The print no format Unicode.
It's like where it gets
interesting.
This first thing I'm going to
comment on this being a
template. I don't understand why
this is a template.
And then Prince?
You would prefer to see a
runtime parameter.
Yeah, I mean it's it's like a A.
Yeah, I I would prefer to see
like if I knew line, push back
and and whack at like.
It seems very odd.
Is actually code operational
idea?
So if context.
I can I can easily change that
as I revise it in response to
your feedback. Would you
additionally wanna see like an
enum class? That's that's the
thing I thought about. I didn't
end up making that change or
commenting about it. But it's a
pool. And if we start passing it
as like a runtime parameter, it
seems reasonable to make an add
new line. Yes? No.
Umm, you know class just so it's
sort of more self documenting.
I.
You don't have a strong opinion
on that, I think.
Fine either way.
Like.
Yeah, I guess the meaning
password probably be better, but
I'm not like super ******** but
that.
OK. If you're not opposed, I'll.
I'll make that change.
And I know Charlie, who is also
on the call.
Yeah, I I if we had multiple
bulls then it would be a slam
Preview version.
dunk with one bull. I agree.
It's sort of, you know, yeah,
kind of nice to have, but if I'm
gonna change it, I'll do that.
So I agree that.
Avoiding the template parameter
should probably reduce some
instantiation duplication, and
it's not gonna complicate the
code, so that's a great thing to
bring up.
And this should just become
like.
Outfit stir equals the deep
format and then if a new line
push back a new line.
Their lives are move.
I'm I'm I'm move I.
With the final call that makes
me happy.
Directly instantiated into the.
So alright.
Looks like the only real
interesting thing here is
Prince. No format Unicode.
This is called in both the print
Unicode info.
As well as printable. Basically
it's saying OK if you're.
If you're if you have format
orgs, you know if you write
something like stood print.
Cool.
Center.
If you actually write this, then
we do need to do the beep print.
We need to do an allocation.
However, if you just write stood
print you know hello.
City.
That's fine.
Ohh that's that's great.
Well, the VS code terminal
emulator being not very nice
inside.
It works that much.
Yeah. So if if we just write
the, you know, stood print
hello, blah, then you shouldn't
get a a duplicated string. They
can just direct me.
Right.
And we do need, we need to
escape thing.
Ohh.
OK.
That doesn't make me happy.
I think that.
It's actually unescaped braces.
I could be wrong.
But it's because the.
Yeah, it's, it's.
That if if they haven't given us
any four hours, so they they're
saying something like Hello
World, it's still in format
syntax. So if it has like brace
brace and then close close those
should be collapsed down. So
that's what that escape braces
Yeah.
does. Now function is actually I
think it may be is it reverse
named now that I think about it
it made sense to me when I
reviewed it but I think it might
be named opposite.
Yeah, it's definitely reverse
named.
It's unescaped really.
Yeah, I was reviewing it at like
the micro level. I was like, oh,
Uh.
we should do. Morgan, this
condition to make it
comprehensible. And I never even
thought about the naming.
So I'll I'll make that note that
it should be unescaped.
Have.
Have feelings about this?
And field.
Spelling.
OK.
And that actually that flows
through to all the variables
because it's we're not returning
an escape still it's returning
on escape star. I I can make
those changes. That's a good
catch.
And this is necessary like
because the format syntax has
us.
We we have to handle the double
double dot braces.
There, there's no way to pass a
raw raw string saying no, no,
It's.
I've I've, you know, put bear
braces here and just don't mess
with them. I don't want you to
do any sort of translation, but
it's all in memory. We shouldn't
be too slow.
Yeah.
Technically, we do allocate
here.
I I'm convincing myself that
it's worth it to do this rather
than just pass to me format.
You'll be tumbling about, OK.
So we do actually have to escape
the thing.
Escape the braces because if you
write for example print, you
know hello.
And this is still 0 characters,
0 arguments, but it needs to
actually print.
With that.
OK, with this OK with this.
I'm not happy about that.
Alright. OK. So we check if it's
an ordinary literal encoding.
Then we print no format uniform
unless we print no format non
unit.
This one is boring. This one all
kind of boring you care about is
this print? No. Format Unicode
because this also gives directly
goes and print no format.
Hello.
Love you.
So.
To print no format Unicode.
Look at this code, this is like.
Interesting code. This is what
actually turns the.
UTF 8 input we at this point we
know that the input is UTF A.
Working so we know that you're
code page that you're that
you're compiling and whack you
TF8 mode, in which case we
assume that your car stairs,
your your care stars.
Are you typing?
So.
Let us check if this screen
cause this stream might be a
file.
It might be a.
A pipe.
And in those two cases, we're
writing bites, and so we just
write UTF 8 to that.
However, if you've got a console
again, we have to actually.
UTF 16 as opposed to YouTube, we
cannot write bytes, so let's
look in print dot CPP.
Don't get Unicode console handle
from filestream.
Don't discard, which is good.
Success returned on error equals
to men error success.
It's good Unicode console
retrieval result.
Something interesting, so this
can be.
The console handle so in.
And windows.
Pretty much everything is a.
Everything passed around as
handles.
The console output.
And then so we're grabbing a
console handle. I'm a file star.
Now we put in here.
In this error. So if we have
student error success, the
operation completed
successfully.
This means that.
The file star that was passed
in.
Was actually a console. It was
not a file.
Found.
That means that the.
That the that the file star
passed in was not a console.
Stood when they're not
supported.
But file star.
Doesn't have an output stream
that. That means that it's like
stood in or something and all
you can only take input.
Instead, when error invalid
parameter.
That's broken like you've passed
in an invalid file star.
So.
Look at where this is called.
It might also be worth noting
that this machinery exists
because we don't directly
include the Windows headers in
STL headers, because they're
enormous and enormously
polluting, and ideally one would
use. That's why we have like
Yes.
stood win error instead of
directly using AD word. We have
our own enum and this really
morally is astute expected. It's
expected console handle and the
errors when error, but we don't
use it because we were trying to
have.
A flat sea interface for
anything that's in the import
Lib.
So, oddly enough, while we are
the providers of awesome tech,
like stood expected, we throw it
all away and we go down to the
simplest see stuff for our Avi
because it gives us the most
flexibility.
Yeah, it turns out that C++ is
not great at ABI boundaries.
Yeah, this song.
The same ABI spa lot, easier to
keep.
Strictly ABI compatible.
And so you'll see in a lot of
ABI libraries that care about
ABI. I also work on address
sanitizer, and we do this here
as well. If you're library cares
about ABI, or like talking
between DLL.
I.
Please the boundaries should be
seen.
Because Pass introduces a lot
of.
Ways that you can break me back
pretty easily.
So.
Different cases we've got
success, in which case it's
Unicode console Unicode console.
I want found in which case you
know it's a file or a.
Right, in which case it's not
Unicode, and so we just write
bytes.
It's not supported.
Return. That means that there's
past instead in or something.
And the default.
We just throw the the error.
Should I have? Is it? Is it not
a?
I'm going to try and print to
stood in.
That seems odd to me.
I don't know what the on the
standard says.
Now let's take a look.
Actually like to read the actual
C++ drop here.
But.
You print the onion a code.
Ordinary literal encoding
issues.
OK, keep me.
Previous strain is a valid
pointer to an output C stream.
OK, so that's that is incorrect.
We should.
We.
No.
Just saying.
This is so you're trying to
output to an.
So your your audio is breaking
up. I I didn't hear what you
said.
I'm sorry. Sorry. Sorry, sorry.
OK.
To if you're trying to print to
an input only strain.
It's this precondition.
What we do now?
As we return.
Which seems wrong to me. We
don't report an error.
So. So in the STL.
We we try not to Reis specially
don't throw exceptions for
preconditioned violations.
Usually we ignore them like you
just can't Billy preconditions
if you do all all bets are off.
Silently ignoring them is not as
bad as throwing an error, but
you're right, it's kind of
squirrely.
The the closest president is we
used to have a case in it was
either list top back or deck pop
back where if the thing was
empty, if the container was
empty we just ignored it and
that's actually bad tolerating
non non standard code
preconditioned violating code
just by silently doing nothing.
That's not as good as having a
debug error or something. This
should, I think, at a minimum we
should probably assert.
Umm these are, you know IDL
check or still still verify,
then we can, you know return or
something. But that's a good
Yeah.
catch. I didn't even realize
that.
There was a precondition there.
And.
We want to your father.
So.
About if it's been a good
console or if it's not,
otherwise it's an error.
Everyone is it's precondition
relation. This is also a
precondition violation.
To be clear.
Now one, I wonder what it
runtime could cause that.
This is like you passed a null
file star or a an invalid file
You're right.
star.
Yeah, that does seem like we
shouldn't throw an exception.
On the other hand, if it's only,
I mean obviously no super bad,
but if it if something goes
wrong in like the internals of
the CRT and it returns, you know
some unknown error code, it does
seem reasonable to throw a
runtime error for that.
That's a hard question because
we definitely don't want to
throw for obvious precondition
violation. But for runtime
errors, throwing his reasonable.
And Zack, so it's not supported.
Ohh I see what it is it's saying
it doesn't have an associated
output stream. This is like if
you.
Whack to know.
OK. That makes sense. That's
valid. It's just where it's
This this is not.
going into the ether, so.
So we just don't have to do
anything, OK? Never mind. OK,
OK.
this makes sense.
So file no returns -, 2 if
stream refers to either stood
out or stood there, and there is
no associated output stream.
Perfect. This is not a
precondition violation. It's
wrong.
Never.
I think this is just a bad
comment.
I'm saying.
I would like an Excel.
I.
Thing we can worry about later.
And I'll I'll definitely since
since I'll I'll rise to response
So.
to your comments, I'll test that
see what happens when we
redirect a null and if it goes
through not supported then we
can have that as a comment.
That's a great catch.
This this is like the perfect
comment for what should be in
the the header.
So then if it's -, 1.
This is our parameter.
Otherwise it must be valid, so
we get the console handle.
Which we can do by reinterpret
casting to handle of death OOF
handle.
Because that was the candle
recount. Ohh so it doesn't
happen, but that's that's OK. So
we get the handle.
If it's an invalid handle value,
can we get an invalid parameter?
You have FD as invalid which.
Precondition language.
I get console mode.
You can try to get free
counseling number. I can return
value again.
If it's not a Unicode console.
And our error is not found.
OK, fine.
Wise we set we console handle
to.
Reinterpret casted.
Council Randall.
Yeah, I believe that that's true
and the error 2 stood when error
success.
So the only two we care about is
pilot pallets access success
case. We return two and found
case we return we have you know
good console of faults.
This is gonna code console.
Successful higher we have to
flush.
Because of this, if the native
Unicode API is used, the
function flushes the string
buffer before writing code. So
flush the string.
The Flash was unsuccessful.
Error.
Like to be in a code console.
And if it?
Was it successful?
Throw US system error.
Cool.
Alright, now the final thing we
have to check is stood printing
in a code.
That's the most interesting part
of this.
This all this rest of this stuff
is just checking whether we
should write directly bytes or
directly in the code or
indirectly I guess Unicode.
We're saying, OK.
You've gotten to the point where
we are writing Unicode.
To this works.
No.
No reason that we're doing this
really basic string view
allocated string.
Stop.
For the.
Just including string view.
This exists because this is
being injected into the import
Lib, so we cannot drag in stood
string and even just dragging in
like string view which is
provided in the same header is
extremely unwise. So we want to
not drag in anything that could
possibly depend on iterator
debug level and the more STL
machinery drag in the riskier it
is. So this handwritten stuff is
lower risk even though it seems
like it's unnecessary.
Alright, sounds.
OK.
Now that I'm now that I
mentioned that now I worry about
So.
that graphene break property
iterator. Where is that coming
from? Is that something that's
scary to drag into the import
Lib? I didn't check that.
And I should have because I have
suffered more than anyone should
ever suffer based on stuff
getting into the input layer
when it shouldn't.
Unicode iterate.
Unless we see, you know, code
which of the core hunter.
It doesn't claim to be core, it
just drags in Yvals core. But if
you look at line one, it doesn't
have a comment about core there.
It does seem that it's fairly
minimal though.
We might. We might be OK here.
The tables are super minimal,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I think Jack utility
limits and sister then are all
well, it's these event of
course, but limits and actually
utility are both.
I don't think X utility is EXE.
Utility is a big one that's got
a lot of runtime stuff. It's got
the vectorized algorithms that's
4.
super not core. Yeah, it's
includes why's age so.
Good point.
This is not OK.
Did Unicode iterators drag it
in? What? What was the dragging?
What was it including? Was that
coming in through the tables?
Yeah.
And I didn't see the whole chain
of.
It's coming in from the UCD
tables.
Ah.
It's and that's why you see the
tables which drugs and acts
utility which drags and.
Ah, that's generated. Ohh no.
OK. Yeah, that that's a real
that's a problem.
Yeah, that's sucks.
It seems like the cables are
just static data. We shouldn't
need X utility. What? What are
we even using ohh lower bound?
Yeah, we we can, we can hand
write something there. Ohh boy.
Stood up about yeah.
I would rather extract lower
bound and just have a
handwritten 1 here rather than
drag and actually tell if we if
we got injected in the. This is
not a problem.
Yeah, this is easy to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or upper bound
here. This is not a problem for
format cause forehead has like
the non the non queries non core
header ever. But now we're
injecting something into the
import Lib for this graphene
break stuff and.
Yeah. Hmm. Interesting.
The whole reason we have the
graphene break is so we can
transcode in segments of 8K, but
I wonder if we should just
allocate and just fail if
somebody tries to stood print
over 2 gigs.
That's the other alternative to.
And even this winter.
You got.
When did actually write code
like this?
Standard library.
Sorry, say that again. I was
talking over you.
Sorry, I just said that I wrote
code like this for the rest
standard library, so I haven't
been.
Because I contribute to other
people's standard libraries as
well.
What I really need to do here is
make it so that we cannot
include anything noncore in the
import Lib. We're like one step
away from being able to validate
that this should be caught
programmatically.
Let me guess.
I had deferred that because we
were busy with other things and
it's actually kind of obnoxious
to untangle the last remain
anything in X facet, but this is
an indication where we really
need that validation. I'll have
to think about that.
We definitely need untangle.
This quested print. This is the
We just.
most significant issue.
Add the defiant that this
allows.
Now the problem is I'm currently
X facet is including a non core
I'm 4 headers.
header. In theory it's not doing
anything bad but trying to add
that compile time block will
break it. So that's why I backed
away from doing that.
Umm, but I I should try again.
In theory it should be
intangible, it just needs some
work.
And that would have caught this
issue.
So to so to solve this, do you
think we should?
Try to make the graphene break
stuff core. Or should we just?
Not transcoding chunks and just
tried to transcode the whole
thing, and if it's over the two
gig limit cause the underlying
API has 22 gig limit, just fail.
So.
But I did OK cause cause I've
implemented this code before for
rust.
When I did was.
I basically just.
Created and 8192.
Right stack buffer.
Transcoded.
4009 or I guess it's a 4096 W
care stock buffer. I transcoded
4096 cares at a time.
If.
This is Unicode.
If they if they were Unicode
then.
There is a.
Then you won't fill the entire
buffer.
Alright.
Isn't that big video kind of a
thing so.
Actually.
I don't think I understand how
that avoids the problem that the
Is it OK for me to?
Yeah.
graphene back iterator is trying
to solve here.
So.
Can we look at my Rust code
actually cause this? Might it
might explain it better if I.
I show what I'm actually trying
to explain.
Ohh, how is it licensed? I kind
of don't wanna see it.
I think it's.
T Apache.
I would. I would prefer not to
put it on this video or to see
it myself.
Keep my brain clean, even if it
theoretically is possible.
Yeah, I did write it.
Yeah.
So so the issue I do know a
little bit here because I I did
So I wonder.
test this, this is that the
graphene break iterator is
Yeah.
trying to solve is that UTF 8
can be up to what was it 4
bytes.
Yes.
Conclude to you know, encode any
you know code point. Or is it 6
bytes? No, that's four.
And we don't want to try to.
Break on.
8192 bytes if that's gonna
interrupt a UTF 8 segment, we
need to stop and do only whole
code points at a time. I'm
sorry, code unit code points.
I'm I'm confused but.
Code points, code points.
Points OK.
And so that's what this iterator
does is it knows those
So I'm gonna. I'm gonna explain.
I'm gonna explain.
boundaries.
Explain a little bit so in
Unicode.
Units.
I'm sorry, code points.
Being number assigned to a
specific.
Character.
And so they are the minimal.
Like.
Element.
I've a piece of Unicode text.
So code point is that unit. So
for example if we look up
smiling Kitty.
There is an example in the in
the repo. If you look for it.
Is there?
Yeah. Look for under score emoji
and you'll find the test code
that has the the escape.
Just don't do a whole word or
case sensitive.
Yeah, there you go.
OK, so this X1 F 408 is this
little friendly Kitty?
So this little friendly Kitty is
represented by the number.
Hacks 1F408.
So the code point.
As you plus.
01 after 408.
OK.
No. In order to store Unicode,
we don't generally want to
store.
They 22 bit number.
Ohh Unicode code points are 22
bits.
And the smallest power of two
that you can that that can store
that is 22 and so UTF 32 is the
standard for life.
I just want a thing that can
hold a single code point that's
called UTF 32.
This is the rust terror type,
for example, is a is a Unicode
codepoint.
But you have to.
Then if you want to store it or
to write it to a screen, you
need to either have it in UTF
eight which.
Every unit of UCF 8 is event.
Or you have 16. Whichever unit
of UTF 16 is 16 bits.
And if you look at the lines
above the comment you just
So.
added, those have all three
representations, the UTF 8, the
16 and the 32. They're all
there.
So thanks for the reminder. I
gotten confused between code
points and code units.
Yeah. So we're seeing here.
This code point if we wanted to
see it in UTF 8.
Would be the bytes F09F9088.
And this is basically this is
the initial character.
An F0.
Means that there are 4 units.
In this.
You look at the the binary, it's
zero B 11110000.
This says OK first.
This is the start of a UTF 8.
Code.
This code unit starts in UTF 8
code.
Right.
There are four ones, so this is
4.
It's wrong.
The top 4 bits.
I've been code point R0.
Next one is X9, so would be 0B.
010.
These top two bits say ohh I'm a
continuing code unit.
And then the next 6 bits of this
code point are 01.
111.
This is saying OK.
I'm 4 units long.
My top four bits are.
Right.
Orbit our 0000, then 01, then
1111, then 01, then 0000, then
00, then 1000.
So this is how UTF a code units
get turned into a code point.
Similarly here this is the UTF
16 representation of the exact
same thing.
So what we want?
Is.
Here.
Can't break property iterator.
We need to find a pointer to the
last valid code point.
And Twitter.
We need to make sure that when
we're converting from UTF 8 to
UTF 16.
We don't attempt to convert.
Up to the middle of a code.
Right.
So we have, you know.
Zero X 11000000. That means
that's a 2 by code unit code
point.
We don't want to only have that
one at the end and then miss the
remaining parts of the code
point. The remaining units of
the code point.
And so we need to find.
The final.
In code point that we can
actually like convert.
And you make sense.
Yeah. And I think also based on
the comment, I think this is
actually doing something even a
little bit more fancier because
it's talking about characters
that consume more than one code
point. And I think that's like
combining characters where you
have like C and then squiggle
and then accent and stuff like
that and write console W wants
to see all those at once. So I
think if we do any sort of
partial convert and print some
convert and print some loop, we
do need this iterator. But if we
do it all at once, I think we
don't.
So that's basically my question
for refactoring this code is
should we try to make the
graphene big property iterator
totally? You know, core
freestanding ish? Or should we
just throw it all away and say
we can just do the conversion
all at once. But if it's over 2
gigs or whatever, then just we
fail, which seems highly
unlikely that somebody would try
to shove that through stood
print.
In theory, it's should work, so
I guess.
Investigating and seeing if we
can eliminate the X utility
dependency is reasonable.
Certainly a probably be less
invasive. I guess I could try
that first, but I was wondering
what your thoughts are.
So.
Explain a little bit the
difference between those
Griffing break property iterator
and what we might consider like
a.
That's good. Point is that you
can have multiple code points
that combine together to create
one graphical character on the
screen. So very obvious one is.
If you do. Let's see.
OK.
It's on my keyboard. Let me
switch to.
See.
So if we have a.
In with a acute accent, there
are two ways to represent this.
In Unicode, you can either
represent it as E with acute
accent.
Which would you know, I said it
back to English because I don't
know this keyboard very well.
3E.
Yeah. Thank you, accent. And
that would be one code point or
you can do E and then acute
accent.
Two code points with this code
is trying to do is trying to
make sure that we don't break.
Being code points that form the
same character.
My question would be.
Do we need to break? Do we need
to make sure that we don't break
between 2 characters that form
the same code?
Then from the same wrapping.
He like, did you test and make
sure that we couldn't write
console down, WWE write console
W combining acute accent mark.
So so I tested a different case
because I didn't realize that it
was the combining character case
that we really cared about. I
tested the special the new emoji
like Black can't that uses the 0
width joiners.
You know, cap and then Black
Square with a 0 withdrawing her
in between. That should be
displayed as black add emoji and
this code correctly handles that
regardless of exactly where that
10 byte sequence appears on the
8K boundary. It gets printed as
a whole black cat emoji, but I
didn't test the E with the cute
accent. That is a good question.
Expect is that you could just
print the first part of the
graphene cluster and then the
second part of the graphene
cluster.
I would actually be surprised if
that would work, because right
So that's my question.
console W if you gave it an E
and you say just print this E
it's gonna print an E and then
if you give it a free standing
accent and you say print this, I
think it's not going to go back
and try to update the character
it already printed. I think
that's going to fail.
So I think this graphing break.
Is necessary.
Yeah.
Yeah. Then this means that the
rest of the library has problems
with it. So let let let's try
this. So don't be TWC.
Making calls.
Or.
Better.
He.
Finally.
This file format website is very
useful for stuff like this.
X301, right? Yeah, there we go.
We write console W.
Handle you see.
For characters writers too.
For characters written.
This is see.
That was not see, OK.
You know doing wrong here.
I think you need to look at the
right Council W docs. I think
there's a function need to call
to map that stood out. We'll
handle constant to an actual
handle.
I am not a Windows 32 programmer
and this and this PR I I joked
Yeah.
before they we started this
review that I overhauled the
test code to use Windows
semaphores and that is the most
I've programmed in the Windows
API the long time.
Most of the time I see response
but platform specific.
That's it handled.
It's good handle.
Yeah, that's it.
Take some man stood handle.
You're looking at a set, not
yet.
But I'm looking at.
Thank you.
You run this, we should get.
No.
Now.
If you do it one at a time.
Here we go.
We do get it. That's what I
thought would happen.
That's very interesting. I have
supplied that that works.
So you do not.
Yeah. So you do not need to do
the graphing break code.
That was when I was tracking.
This this says to me that we can
do the far more simple case of
going to the end of the string.
Are going to the end of the 8192
bytes.
And then popping back until we
find a.
At the beginning of a code white
and use that as like the end
pointer. Does that make sense?
Yeah, because we we can
recognize the boundaries between
UTF 8.
Reckon you recognize the
boundaries between code points
and UTF 8 stream without caring
about exactly where we are,
because the the values tell us
whether we're starting a new one
or not. That's very easy to do.
That is, that is interesting.
Does write console W say
anything that this works because
I'm I'm a little nervous about
depending on the results of 1
experiment.
If the documentation said it
could handle it, I would feel
better.
It probably doesn't mention it
though, because this is pretty
obscure.
It does not say anything about
graphemes.
OK, silent, interesting.
Point clusters.
Sure looked like it worked
though.
Yeah. So we should do more
testing.
Yeah.
Staying but it seems.
I mean, we could do simple
search back for the beginning of
a code point.
There time.
You can have a graph you.
I am still tempted to just say.
Go back.
What if we don't break it into a
K segments? And what if we just
do it all at once?
Because the the whole reason I
think we were originally
avoiding this is because we
wanted to lock, but then we
decided that we don't actually
need to lock when we do this.
So I wonder if the the argument
for breaking it up into a K
segments and still holds.
So the original reason that we
did this was because I didn't
like that we were.
Doing allocation. I wanted us to
do it in a stack buffer.
Taking an 8K stack buffer or
something?
Because that's how I implemented
it. Erupt, basically.
Hi I'm certainly allocating a
slower. I think we're already
allocating in many cases if we
print the new line because that
stood string.
You're right, it's a potential
performance issue. The thing is,
if we're physically writing to a
console, I wonder, I really
wonder if it matters because the
console performance, I mean,
they've improved it, but I think
that's gonna dominate.
I haven't profiled this at all,
but I would be very surprised if
Yeah.
our allocation were the limiting
step in like physically printing
the console also.
If you're physically printing to
the console how many like you
know gigs, can you print before
it just scrolls by too fast for
the user to see? Like at that
point you redirect your file
anyways because you don't wanna,
you know, have the console
printing slow down. So I wonder
in that case because we're
actually displaying stuff to the
user if it matters.
Whereas if we were, if this were
on the print to a file path, we
Yeah, that was.
were could run completely
headless, then yeah, yeah. I
would be like, OK, we don't
wanna allocate.
Yeah, my my feeling is kind of
like.
If you're printing more than
4000.
Caracteres to the console.
They don't care about your
health case very much.
And.
Like.
Will be smaller amounts that
we're that you print. I would
rather not allocate. So like if
you just do it in 4K chunks.
You can 2K chunks like it's not
a big deal.
Especially because we don't have
to do this graph being
clusterization.
I would rather not.
Rather not allocate whenever
possible.
I think it's a reasonable The
thing is, the code has already
written so slightly adjusting it
to use the simpler technique of
just finding the next UTF 8
boundary, which we can detect
with a simple it's arranged
test. I just need to look on
Wikipedia to see what the value
is.
Yeah.
That would be that would be
simple.
Checking right thought test
really really like you. Just you
just search for the last
character that has either the
top 2 bit set or.
Not the top bit set.
Yeah, that can be done with
handwritten code by effectively.
Either.
Either there will be 0 XXXXX.
Or is there will be 1/1?
That's all we care about. We
need to find one of these two
characters, one of these two.
You know that now.
We come in my.
OK.
We're doing a bunch of
transcoding multiplied twig car.
To beat you today. Yep, that
makes sense.
It string Yep.
Yeah, this is the accounting
number occurs required.
It's the number of character
required is greater than.
Gratian string dot capacity let
me reset it.
So we all allocating in this
case.
Right.
Yeah, I don't believe we
actually use a stack buffer.
We use the the allocated string.
Yeah. So we're basically saying,
OK, we're going to allocate.
Shut down.
Up to 8192 and it's The thing is
a big tracking thing, then we'll
do random stuff, but we don't
need to have all that stuff. So
this is a lot of complexity
basically.
Which will go away once we
remove the graphene
clusterization style.
Well, I think that I think all
that complexity will stay. It's
just the graphene bit means that
the the step define the
boundaries simpler, but we're
still doing in chunks, so it
still needs allocated to stir.
This doesn't sure that the user
comes to us with like a mega
text. We simply reuse the same
8K buffer. So after the first
allocation we are non allocating
and we can reuse it. So that's
nice.
Yeah, that that's definitely
true. But on the other hand
like.
What's happening is every time
you call print, you get a new
allocation.
Already do get an allegation.
It's not make me happy, but we
do do an operation.
Broke for a SEC. One SEC.
Ohh but like the this checking
for.
This if it's greater than
capacity, we do not need to
worry about this at all.
I don't think.
Now we do cause it starts off
with new capacity I believe.
No, I see what happens.
Yeah, this is trying to avoid
like allocating 8K every time
but.
It it doesn't need to allocate.
So I think.
The only other comment is I
would like this to be a stock
buffer.
The thing is, like I would worry
about that we we try to be
pretty.
Conservative in our use of stack
space because we don't know how
much is available. The user
could already be in a pretty
deep call stack by the time they
call the STL, and if we overflow
the stack, it's unrecoverable.
Umm, the the largest things we
have in the STL like the random
number generators which are like
2 or 4 kilobytes. I forget how
big and that's unavoidable from
version twist or and in CARICOM
I had literally no choice but to
use a stack buffer cuz we
physically cannot allocate now
we're no fail. So there I had to
use like a one KB stack buffer
and I felt super bad about it
because I was like I don't know
how close we are.
But that that was like the upper
limit. AK is a lot. I don't. I
don't think we can do that. It
seems risky for a potential
optimization. The thing is, I'd
rather keep what we have now.
Because we can revise it in the
future if we find that
performance is an issue, the
internal usage of a buffer here
we can change that without other
code needing to care because
we're not passing it across
functions. So I'd kind of rather
stupid for what we have and then
if we profile and we're fine,
Right.
this is actually problem.
Somebody calling stood print
with fairly small strings. Then
we can go back and say, well,
what if we use like a 1K buffer
and then if it's over that then
we allocate you or just
something fancier but.
Yeah.
We refer to avoid starting with
a big stack buffer. That seems
like premature optimization in a
way that could decrease
reliability.
It OK, so the one thing I will
say is that.
This.
Probably doesn't need to exist
like like what we care about is.
At work we can allocate.
Enough always, because we know
that the size and W cares is
always.
Points that are equal to the
size in careers.
So we could just allocate the
number of terrors.
If that makes sense.
Oh, I see. I see what you're
saying.
Because it's a, it's A at most a
constant factor more.
The the question is, does that
actually save anything because
the initial allocation is?
A could cause we're we're doing
it exactly. So you're saying we
could have a case where the
initial string is 8K occurrences
of a?
Yeah.
No, no, the opposite. The
initial string is a bunch of big
emoji that.
Consume. You know, they're like,
you know, 4 byte each or
something. And then so we we say
ohh we only need 2K W carts. No,
we've got the uh the combining,
they actually use surrogates.
OK, so the case, maybe it might
may not be as simple as that,
but it's the initial stuff is
all.
So we have a bunch of Chinese
text that takes up 3 bytes in
Yeah.
UTF 8.
Yeah, and then collapses down to
smaller UTF sixteens. And then
And takes up.
next one is all a bunch of ASCII
A's that do need the whole 8
case that we do 1 allocation and
then we discover we need to
resize. Then we hit the high
watermark and anything beyond
that we can reuse the
allocation. So that doesn't seem
like the end of the world. The
number we're actual
reallocations is fairly small.
It does seem like just allocate
a constant factor more the
promise that stood string
insists on initializing
everything. So if we allocate
more than we need, we actually
initialize all that stuff to 0.
At least the first time.
Which seems also in desire.
You're not using stood string.
Yeah.
CRT unique. He put her don't
way. Yeah, we Malik. And then we
Yeah.
move. And then I think it
scribbles a null Terminator.
Yeah, that's a good argument in
favor of just allocate a little
bit more than you need.
So you're saying it's?
N right, because you can never
have more WRT coming out than
care is coming in.
That's compelling. That's only a
lot simpler.
Yeah.
I could be convinced of that if
we're going to allocate then.
Make it a little simpler there.
Yeah.
Because like, it's not.
Not much more. I mean, actually,
I would argue it's probably not
at all and more expensive to
allocate.
4K or 8K then it is to allocate
4K2K.
You're still allocating a page
or two pages or whatever.
Yeah, right. But other then then
this really like if we're gonna
simplify that, then they're
really pushes me towards. Let's
just do the whole conversion all
at once. Like none of the same
case stuff. Throw it all away.
If we're gonna allocate, like
just allocate.
Enough space to convert the
users whole string and then
later maybe go optimize it.
With, you know something fancy
stack, buffer, whatever. But
what do I basically worry about?
Is the OK, I could change the
code to March backwards a bit
and find that UDFA boundary, but
that's introducing more risk if
we do the conversion of all at
once, then we know that if the
basic stuff works, all the
complicated stuff works too.
And but I'm getting nervous that
we're rising at the PR's logic
close sort of to the end and.
Going with something simpler
seems even if it's a bigger code
change, it's gonna result a lot
simpler code. I think I'd prefer
to do that because either way
we're gonna allocate and for
most things it doesn't make a
difference like user gonna come
to us with a string that's a few
100 bytes, or maybe a couple K
like in my testing, 8K is
already a whole page that's
already pretty big, so I think
there's gonna be very little
difference between do it in aka
chunks versus do it.
All in a single step, and that
will dramatically simplify the
code, which is I think what
we're both worried about. I
prefer to do that change. If
you're OK with that.
Yeah.
I'm gonna that I think.
I would be certainly down if
somebody brought in.
This kind of optimization back
if they show a use case for it.
Or if they are somehow writing
more than two gigs to the
console.
But but yeah, I think this is
reasonable.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
Yeah, certainly, yeah. There's
an optimization PR follow up
that uses a benchmark and we
definitely be open to that.
But the most important thing is
to make sure that we're not
going to paint ourselves into a
corner with an ABI or something
in the import Lib that prevents
us from ever making this better.
We could worst case is we would
need to retain the existing
stuff as is and add something
entirely new to the import Lib a
V2.
Which we could do.
I I am happy with.
I would be happier if this
allocation stuff was. I would be
happier if the allocation stuff
was not on the ABI boundary
like. This is an API boundary.
It is an internal API boundary.
I guess we could make it
transparent UTF 8 string too.
Never mind. Never mind. We can
do transcode either 8 string 2.
No, it's.
Yeah. And importantly, this is
in an unnamed namespace. If you
look at it, it's not marked with
an explicit calling convention.
That's actually one of the
revisions I get, so this is
fully local to this TU yeah. See
this allocated string stuff.
It's all the unnamed new space.
The only ones that are on the
boundary that are actually
linking to user code. Those are
marked stirred call, and they're
just like the right Unicode
console. Whatever. This does not
pass any allocations back and
Perfect.
forth to the header.
Yes.
I just fixed the conscire. Star
says. I'm gonna go print it to
the console somehow through
magic, and we do all the
allocations internally. So I
think that is a good firewall.
We're gonna be ABI safe.
Perfect. I'm happy with that.
I think that's the only thing I
have left. I just wanted to.
The the real the real meat and
potatoes of this is I wanted to
explain to people how Unicode
stuff on Windows worked.
And how Unicode code points work
and I think I succeeded in that.
So hopefully y'all, who are
watching enjoy this.
Semi code reviews Sunny look
into Unicode and how it's
printed on Windows.
Thank you so much for coming to
the VC libs Open code review and
I'll.
He also.